welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice chrissy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author
is my co-host today we're taking your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five you jump in and we
will talk well bad news for those of you
that didn't get in on it
uh but the goal planner the 2021 goal
planner by christie is completely sold
out
yeah and uh there's not gonna be any
more ordered that's it we're done
we already placed the reorder and those
sold out no sold out yeah we already
already went that route but the good
news is the living true
devotional is uh 40 days to get back to
you is
doing extremely well hit the best seller
list and
this thing is powerful yeah this is such
a pain point point for people and it
really has come so much out of not only
my own experience dave
especially in the last six to eight
years but also
women i've talked with all over the
country all stages of life
whether they work outside the home
inside the home run their own business
they're a mom of littles or they don't
have kids it doesn't matter
it's just so easy to lose yourself in
your own life and i know that sounds
kind of weird
but whether it's you lose yourself in
your business or trying to build your
career
or maybe a really difficult season where
you feel like you lose your identity and
just the difficulty of it all
i feel like we all go through that and
so that's why i was so excited to write
this devotional because it's 40 days
so it's very um easily digestible it's
not a big commitment it's 40 days
to help you reset and refocus on the
truth of who you are and what god says
about you
to really help you get that sense that
you've gotten back to yourself and who
you are created to be so it's been a joy
to see this now out in the marketplace
and hear the feedback and see how
god is speaking to people through this
and i'm just so grateful to get to do it
and you know
walking through the emotional and
spiritual impacts of the
economic shutdown right and all the
career impact the
careers that have been impacted and
walking through the uh
just the fear that a lot of people have
had over the pandemic issues
and um it is a good year to have in our
rear view mirror
yes uh and this might be a way to kind
of
i don't know step on the accelerator and
make sure that 2021 is in your
or 2020 is in your rear view mirror for
completely
um so i mean 40 days to get back to you
it could be that getting you're getting
back to you after experiencing 2020.
yeah and i think what's interesting is
even if you are a person of faith and
you say oh i know
my identity is who i am as a child of
god we still have things in our world
that we get a sense of identity from so
our work it's like i this is who i am
this is what i do and you've seen so
many people lose their jobs this year
they they lot they felt like they lost a
piece of themself
in that difficult time or even something
as simple as um
being social and you're always going and
you're always with friends you're always
extroverted that's a part of who you are
and you didn't get to
feel that experience at this year as you
were you know maybe isolated lonely you
know shut down
and so there's all these things that are
our sense of normal this year
that were removed and we're going okay
what's left of me who
am i outside of these things that i
found joy in and they weren't bad things
but
it gave me a sense of who i am and now
who am i when those things are not true
anymore and so
i just i love this opportunity to dig
into scripture
to remind you in any season difficult
seasons or awesome
seasons um that this is who you are and
this is what god says about you and i
think it's just a great
message to go into a new year with for
sure
the devotional is called living true 40
days
to get back to you you can check it out
at daveramsey.com
we're in a ten dollar sale on almost all
of our books there as well so be sure
and check all that open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five abigail is in
springfield missouri
hi abigail what's up hi dave
um not too much how about you better
than i deserve how can we help you
uh yes sir um well me and my husband are
just starting out with your program
we're baby
pre baby step one we're getting
everything sorted out was just wondering
what kind of advice you would have for
someone starting out
and what you would recommend and
everything yeah
well good congratulations we're honored
to have you in the tribe here
i i think what ends up happening is is
you the first step the first thing you
end up doing is you try to figure out
where you actually
are and and that's stuff like making a
list of your debts
and starting to write out your first
budget where you're actually going to
tell your money what to do and make it
behave
and you know and then we're going to
give you a clear path
that we call the baby steps to walk
through
and you may have heard of that
i've been doing already decent amount of
research the last two days
i'm curious i'm curious what led to you
finding dave and the baby steps abigail
kind of how did you get to this point
um i actually saw someone post um on
one of the facebook's pages that i was
at her name's julie goheen
and she was sharing her journey and how
they became debt free
and was talking to her and she offered
to send me the starter book
and everything and then watching your
youtube channel for the last day okay
and everything just getting more and
more excited about it
wow that's cool i'm honored yeah that's
fun to see someone else do it you know
you see someone else on the other side
of being debt-free you're like oh
could i do that you know that's awesome
yeah yeah maybe maybe i could have that
happen to me and i think you can abigail
so
well again welcome aboard so you're
going to sit down do your written game
plan your written budget and you've
already seen that stuff on youtube and
lay out your debt snowball
and begin to attack your debts it's
imperative
that you and your husband work together
uh all of our data christie shows that
couples who work together on almost any
part of their life
right they're more effective at that
part
money parenting careers right building a
business
or whatever i mean if uh if they're if
you guys are working together it just
makes all the difference in the world
and yeah that means one of you is not a
spectator
yeah yeah and it's interesting too
because i feel like that whenever you
are
having these conversations you'll
typically have one one of the things
that abigail said she said i'm getting
excited i was like oh good because the
excitement motivation goes a long way
yeah like
you gotta i always hear you say this
dave you say you gotta get fired up you
gotta get mad sick and tired of being
sick
and tired you can wander into debt you
cannot wander out so emotion does play a
piece of this you can't be just
indifferent
and get out of debt like you've got to
actually care because change is hard but
it's interesting in marriage
i think a lot of times what we see is
there's one person that's excited and on
board and one person that is
less so less excited and so i think
what's cool is if you start having these
conversations on the front end abigail
where you and your spouse are talking
about okay what are our goals
what are our dreams what would it look
like for us to be debt-free what could
we do if we didn't have
payments and then you both start out
excited together you both start out not
only communicating on the budget but
also with the enthusiasm that you both
need to bring to the table to actually
make the change
yeah because you're gonna you have to
bust into some stuff that's gonna be
hard yes
you're gonna have to make some choices
differently right than you've ever made
and
you know we always say you have to live
like no one else so that later you can
live and give like no one else it works
but it's hard yeah this process that we
teach is extremely effective
has a very high probability of you
succeeding
uh but only to the extent that you bust
into it yeah
it is easy to understand what we teach
you to do
it is hard to change your life right and
it's interesting
it's interesting too because we always
say like of all the people the millions
of people that have become debt-free you
know using our program
it's amazing how none of them are going
man i really miss those payments
i really miss being in debt they never
look back with regret and so if you
could see what it will feel like on the
other side
it will give you that motivation and
enthusiasm to push through the hard
stuff initially because it is so worth
it when you get there yeah
very good very good well you keep
listening to ms abigail and we're here
to help you call anytime if we can help
you on this journey
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
the medical bill sharing from chm was
exactly the way the website described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money
all while helping other families
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
lindsay's in portland oregon hi lindsay
how are you
hello hi dave and christy hi what's
going on
so um we are wondering we
have about twenty thousand dollars extra
um and we're trying to decide if we
should use that to pay down our current
mortgage
or if we should put it towards money for
a future house
to do a down payment uh pay down the
current mortgage
but then i have to sell contingent or
buy contingent
and in our market you have to go in like
that's really risky
i mean you don't have to do it today
anyway so by the time you do it it might
not be that way
um that that has to do with the hot the
market being hot if the market's slow
it's not a problem at all so
you know you're gonna have to sell your
house anyway before you buy a house you
have to sell contingent anyway
no not if i yeah i don't want you
keeping two stinking house payments
that's unwise okay that's unwise so you
gotta get rid of the house anyway so
and you're gonna get your money back
obviously
they give you the money we were just
thinking that you know buy where we're
moving
move out sell the house roll that into
the new house
yeah that ends up that ends up with two
house payments if this plan
of yours doesn't work okay
yeah and i would never tell you to sign
up for two house payments no
not a chance so um and i
you know six months later you're still
cranking two house payments no now we're
going to rent it
oh god no you really got a disaster so
no
no no no no no you got to get it sold it
has to work that way anyway
you do whatever you want to do obviously
you're going to but
the uh but i wouldn't tell you to do
that and i personally wouldn't
do that um you know you've got to be
able to get the
you just can't sign up for two house
favorites to kill you
christy the number of times we've run
into problems with people people they're
in here
in serious financial problems because
they did that yeah and so it's just made
me
super leery over the years paul is with
us paul
is in jacksonville florida hi paul how
are you
hey dave how are you uh very exciting to
uh finally be talking to you
you too um uh well here's the thing
so i am four months away from being debt
free
and um i have zero i'm fit well i'm 55
years old
and i have zero for retirement
uh i come out of a bad divorce
and had to pay a lot of debt and
so but i'm four months away and my
question is
is uh what's the best thing for me to do
i mean to invest
money to do i have no idea
okay uh well what we're gonna teach you
to do is
to be debt-free then your next goal is
to have your emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses
right and then once you've done that you
start investing
15 of your income into retirement
do you own a home uh
no i do not okay are you planning on
buying a home
well it's kind of a funny thing i i i
got
remarried and the woman
the love of my life who i got married to
she owns her home
so uh that's where i am okay
well we we are married and we have a
paid for house
right okay cool that's a pretty good
deal you got there
well right well it's not it's not it's
it's not as cute and dry as
that but uh well well let me have you
all combined your finances paul because
you're using a lot of her and i
statements here like we got separate
things going on no ma'am
no ma'am she was married before
and obviously i was married before and
when we went into the relationship
she wanted a prenup so that's what we
did
oh that's what i did and um
that does not prohibit you from working
together
to live your dreams yes sir a prenup
does not make you roommates
well and that is the word that i used
with her one time we had gotten into
a discussion of that and
she she has it in her head that
um she wants to keep it this way and
because she said there's no upside for
me
if you know we combine everything and
because she i'm self-employed and she
uh she makes a lot more money than i do
[Music]
okay um i i think you're uh i think
you're gonna struggle
to build wealth yes sir i because we're
not working together
is essential it's one of the data points
that we see with families that
become wealthy is they work together and
they overcome they
overcome the wounds and the hurts of the
past in order to do that
and uh you're either gonna you know it's
up to you you can do it or not do it but
i'm just telling you that
everything we know about what we do says
that couples that work together have a
much higher probability of living their
dreams
because they are sharing their dreams
and this is not just financial
like i mean i hear it in his voice dave
like this is whether it's because she's
been hurt from her past marriage and she
wants to protect herself
in this new one but but there is some
distrust
not even just at the financial level
that is i think playing out in the
finances and to me that's worth digging
into paul with a counselor or however
you guys want to go about it it's not
just about the numbers and
who manages which account and who has
savings or paid for house it's like
if y'all can't be a team in a marriage
that's a bigger problem than
having separate bank accounts i just i
would say aside from the obvious
financial benefit that dave has already
talked about i would dig into that
because even hearing it in your voice it
sounds a lot like
her and me and we're very separate type
of language and that's
that's a little bit uh concerning to me
it's um
but but aside from that the answer to
your overall question is
you start investing since you don't have
a house payment and i'm
guessing that you're not having to
support kids in college or you would
have mentioned that
then you're down to all you can your
most you have taken the shortest path to
building your own nest egg
uh which is to become debt free and so
normally we would put you at baby step
four
after this but you don't have a house
payment so really you're baby step seven
and so once you get your emergency fund
in place you're gonna max out all
retirement that you can get your hands
on max out of roth ira with a
smart investor pro max out your 401 k at
work or you said you're self-employed
you look at a 4-0 uh a simple ira there
or a sep depending on your situation
smart vester pro can help you with both
of those
so depending on your income you can
really chunk
a bunch of money away quickly and uh
you'd be amazed how big a mistake in 10
years from 55 to 65 that you can build
now that you don't have any payments and
you can focus on that and concentrate on
that
it will be uh
it will be much more efficient and have
a higher probability of
winning if you'll go ahead and deal with
the issues in the relationship as well
that christie's talking about
just again we we do not see people
uh winning at this so let me just back
up folks from this because it feels like
i've done this
twice already in this hour um haven't i
similar similar questions like that um
when we studied the millionaires over 10
000 of them
and we did in-depth research
and surveying and questioning of them
uh one of the things that came out of
that a lot of things that came out that
were not a surprise
and this was not a surprise but what was
a surprise was the
how high the percentages were of
spouses working together sharing the
dream one of them's not dragging the
other one along
one of them's not you know you're not
treating their household separately
uh you know we work together we achieve
our goals together we set big dreams we
both dream we both fight to get there
and that that unity the power of that
unity
uh was apparent in the in
very high percentages yeah in the number
of millionaires that we
researched over 10 000 of them yeah and
so it's not like the
the data is inconclusive it's conclusive
right
you know and so you can you do it
without working with your spouse yeah
you can do it
but you're you know 80 of the people
that make it
don't don't don't they work together
right and so it just
and they and they credit their spouse as
one of the reasons that they
are able to get the thing done this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phone's at triple eight
eight two five five two two five john is
with us in dallas texas hey john welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey guys how are you doing today great
how can we help
hey um had a question just regarding a
career change
i'm considering so my wife and i are
currently working through the baby steps
um
almost paid through all of our debt we
will be by next month so we're really
excited about that
and uh appreciate you guys on what you
teach um
my question is though you know the
company i'm working at right now i make
really good money
really happy with it but about a third
of the income that i get from the job is
in the form of stock grants or
restricted stock units
um the stock is doing well we're
performing well we're in a stable
industry
but you know the base salary is lower
and i'm currently considering another
position at another company
also a great opportunity um it would it
would
technically next over the next few years
maybe pay a little bit less but it would
be a much much higher base
and commission package you just wouldn't
have that the stock that comes with it
um so i just was just wondering you know
wanting your guidance on you know how
you'd
help someone determine maybe which path
to go down from a financial perspective
how long is the stock restricted
um so it's going to be vesting over the
next three and a half years
and i get to cash it out every quarter
um
so it's a 1 16 cash out every quarter um
for the next three and a half years so
um it's going to be about it's going to
be netting around 10 000
every quarter after taxes um
so what is your what is your income now
counting the stock
counting the stock as long as it stays
where it's at next year my income will
be around two hundred thousand
and what would your income be at the
other place
uh about 160 to 170 what field
what field are you in software sales
okay all right 10 years from now
you're 10 years older your kids are 10
years older
which one are you glad you did
probably the new company i'm considering
why
i think there's a there's more career
mobility it's it's a bit of an early
earlier stage company um you know i
think
i have the opportunity to advance faster
um
you know i i and i think that the
company met now i i don't like the idea
of so much of my income
you know it's about a third of my income
is rested on a single stock doing well
yeah agreed a lot of risk there
and then the other thing is you're in
sales and so if you add value
you're going to add income right true
so i mean i i would talk to the new
company and just say look i'm i'm
struggling with this
and show me how what what i can do to
add enough value
to get my income to 200 with you what
have i got to do to cause that to happen
okay and and if they if they give you
some you know they
get just show me a path how i can add so
much value that you are smiling
when you're paying me 200. right
i like that because i mean if you bring
it you know if you work for me and you
bring in a whole bunch more money and i
share some of it with you that's not
there's no downside to this equation
yeah that's true and so i you know that
you you
can control your destiny so yeah i think
you've answered your own question you
take this job but you just work the
you work for a clear path rather than a
vague sense of
i think i can get my income up give that
have them give you some structure
on how you can do it and that's not
really a salary negotiation it's just
how can i add enough value and then you
know what have i got to do and it's
well if you do you know if you do a good
job we'll take care of you know that's
not what i'm talking about
i'm talking about tactically
specifically
what kind of numbers do i need to
generate so that i
generate two hundred thousand dollars in
income from me and what kind of
what have i got to do that's good for
you guys that makes you really happy
about that
and um i don't know christy what can you
add to that well i think
one of the points that you made is
really good because a lot of people go
into salary negotiations with
i want x or i need x
or i deserve x and nobody really cares
what they care about is what you're
going to do for them
what are you going to do for the company
and so when you come in and say hey what
can i do it's again it's a personal
responsibility angle
what can i do to get to this for me and
for you and i love that angle because
every
leader of any organization is going okay
they're a go-getter they get personal
responsibility they're taking initiative
and what's cool
is then in this initial conversation
john like setting the foundation for a
potential relationship with this company
you're letting them know where you want
to be and where you're working toward
it's not like you work there for three
years wish you made 200 000 you're going
well i really
wish i would have gotten there like we
didn't know you set this plan and this
path
from the get-go and then you're both
working toward it together and you make
that intent very clear but from the
right posture yeah
the reason i'm taking this is i think
this is a wonderful company
and i think it's got a tremendous upside
potential i want that to be a little
less vague
yeah if i uh and so this is you talking
to them
and so what i want to do is i want to
know that i can add value
to this place beyond the deal we're
talking about
that i can be more valuable than that to
you
and that i've you know i've sold more
stuff i've
executed whatever i've created
relationships i've led a team what is it
that i need to do
to be valuable to the organization to
that
level to the 200 000 level and they'll
tell you they'll tell you
and then then it's not a matter of oh
they promised me after six months i'd be
doing so
right now and they promised me when i
did this now did you do it if you did it
then then you're going to get the money
unless they've not got integrity
yeah so that's the whole thing great
great great stuff
yeah take that job uh garrett's in
alexandria virginia hi garrett welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so i just finished college last may and
i recently started my new job and it's
currently time to enroll for next year's
benefits
i'm currently on baby step number four
and i'm calling specifically about life
insurance
um my company offers a group universal
policy
for up to 10 times my income for about
22
a month no um i'll be getting sorry
no you don't buy universal life policies
all right well uh so let me help you
remember remind us why
now let me tell you why okay so that you
don't just do you don't have to do what
dave ramsey says but
here's the thing they have in built into
them
an investment side of it that you're
paying
extra to get the investment portion
of this sucks the other thing that's
built into
a universal policy is the life insurance
side
is what's called an art an annual
renewable term and what that means is
the portion of your dollars that are
going to life insurance goes up
every year as you get older so if you
buy a life insurance policy that is
what we would call pure life insurance
an art an annual renewable term
no one does that in the financial
planning world anymore but they still
sell them out there
that's purely this is what this is what
it costs to cover you at 32.
this is what it costs to cover you at
33. this is what it costs to cover you
at 34.
this is what it costs because it does
cost more to cover you because you're
older and you're more likely to die
statistically actuarial tables and
they're gonna
up so out of your 22 x is going to
life insurance and why is going to a bad
investment
next year x is that's going to life
insurance is larger
so less is going to the investments to
the point that
if this is your whole plan someday the
entire 22 dollars will be absorbed by
just the life insurance cost
and there'll be nothing going to the
investment and then it gets worse than
that
it starts taking out of the investment
to cover the fact that you're even short
later and that's if you keep it years
and years and years and years and years
which you probably wouldn't do
it's a group plan it's a piece of crap
don't buy it
go get life insurance get 15 to 20-year
level term life insurance is the
cheapest way to handle your life
insurance needs
and when you leave your company if
you've had a medical problem
you won't have trouble getting insurance
because you already have insurance
and so you need to you just avoid that
stuff so
go to go to xanderinsurance.com get a
quick easy
quote and you'll just do a whole lot
better there
so chrissy two problems with that
equation number one
the universal life product is a bad
product and i explain why
number two you got all your insurance at
work
yeah and if you get diabetes or have a
heart problem or a cancer scare and you
leave work
you cannot take it it's not portable it
does not go with you
and now you can't you're uninsurable
when you leave you can't get
at your new job you can't get insurance
yeah so you always want your insurance
or at least a larger portion of your
insurance to be independent of work
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five linda is in los angeles hi linda
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi it's actually very funny i just
bumped into your channel for the first
time on youtube and i'm hearing people
ask their life so
i really need some major advice i'm
going almost going through a divorce and
because of financial issues um bottom
line is i was a single mom with two boys
before i remarried
um as a single mom i was here to move my
kids to the streets so i made them a
promise and told them that if they
went to college full-time as long as god
blessed me with health and employment
i would financially take care of them
while they completed school
so they kept their end of the deal they
got accepted into really great schools
and i wanted to as a mom to keep my end
of the deal problem is i got remarried
and my husband's completely against me
helping them financially
they're now 22 i'm sorry 24 and 21
one has one semester left at ucla i'm
sorry at tcu
the next one has a year left at ucla so
have you supported them all this time
i have okay good and he doesn't what he
does
and they're almost done and he's he's
objecting to you
finishing the support 100
he will not contribute financially to
our family because he's upset that i
contribute towards my children but just
the main point that i was calling about
was i don't ask him for anything i pay
for everything for my children he's
never had to contribute anything towards
their school
towards any of their expenses but his
frame of thinking is
i'm not going to contribute to the
family if you're contributing to your
children that already over 20 you need
to cut
the string and they need to fly on their
own but i told them i made this promise
and i just really want to finish it for
them
so he was like it's the kids or our
marriage so i'm just
we're literally he just moved out a few
months ago and i'm just i'm just
literally torn because i don't know what
to do but
i i mean i do know what to do i want to
continue helping my children
yeah yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry yeah
linda i'm just i'm really sorry you're
in this situation it hurts
yeah and um am i wrong am i wrong no
you're not you're not wrong i am no
you're not wrong no
and he tells me all the time because i'm
a christian woman and he tells me this
all the time
you're christian and you need to submit
your husband and if i don't approve of
it
um you need to respect them let me help
you let me help you with this okay if
your husband's doing cocaine
and wants you to pay for it and he says
you're supposed to submit to me
then that's not what the bible's talking
about okay
so submit does not mean endorsing
misbehavior
okay that's not what it means uh
at all and so uh he probably needs to
get a little better
bible study going because he didn't
understand that concept
but um and he probably needs to get the
idea that you're supposed to like
serve each other and now what i'm
interested in
and number one let me just tell you i
don't think this is gonna go well
with what you've described i think
you're i think i think you're on the
path
of your marriage ending and let me help
you it is not
because you supported your children okay
your marriage is ending because it was
not built on
mutual respect and agreement
your marriage is ending because you had
made a deal prior to getting married
he knew about that deal and then after
getting married
was not okay with it and tried to change
it
and punished you for it and punish you
for it so your marriage is not ending
because you're supporting your kids
framing the narrative that way to try to
box you into
your choosing between me and them but
that's not what's happening at all
that's not that's not it at all it this
has to do with him not getting his
little way
and that's what's going on it's
incredibly manipulative as well
like to say john believes to say that
you have to choose between
supporting an adult child or me is
incredibly
yeah he he is the one that is spinning
up this narrative and put you in this
position that is not actually what's
going on
and he put you in this position you did
not put yourself in this position
so uh if you're my little sister linda i
would here's what i would tell you today
i would tell you to be sure you are
seeing a marriage counselor
and if he wants to go that it would be
great you can have
a mediator to try to help you guys learn
through how to communicate
and how to um work and navigate through
things we disagree on
okay and if he won't go you should go
anyway because you need someone in your
corner reminding you that you're not
crazy and you're not wrong okay
okay and uh if you're not in a good
church
get in one and you need to get in touch
with the church staff
and sit with a pastor and tell them
what's going on
so you've got people praying for you
that love you well
and that are explaining that submission
does not mean endorsing
misbehavior or endorsing
bad concepts uh you know i i've been
married 38 years
as a believer as a person of faith
and i have never one time told my wife
she needed to do
something because that i wanted her to
do
because she was supposed to submit i
don't have to
it doesn't come up um and because we're
in agreement
we're communicating we're navigating the
decision making together
and she knows i have her best interest
at heart we don't know that about your
husband
he does not seem to have your best
interests at heart he seems to be
selfish
with the story you've told anyway so no
you're not crazy darling
you're just going through hell and uh
i'm sorry
uh it hurts and it hurts to be torn
between
uh to be put in a position that you feel
like you're torn between two different
competing relationships and that's not
fair
and it's wrong especially there's no way
he doesn't know this deal happened prior
you know he didn't come into this blind
no so
ah that's so hard hurtful so hard
here's what i will tell you guys out
there uh it seems like we've had a
little bit of a marriage
uh our theme today uh christy we have
experienced this
that uh you know i use proverbs 31 a lot
who can find a virtuous wife for her
worth is far above rubies the heart of
her husband
safely trusts her and he
will have no lack of gain now for you
ladies that means virtuous
it does not give you permission to be
the holy spirit that's not your job
your virtuous and you're kind and you're
thoughtful and you're
you're smart and you're entrepreneurial
and you're energetic and you're adding
value to the conversation and when
sharon ramsey does that
because she has done that for 38 years
is one of the reasons we're so vastly
freaking successful here
is that that pulling together that thing
that unity
thing and um to discount
the voice of
either spouse is just it's uh
it's so destructive it does not work and
it does not cause success
yeah and and it's amazing too how i feel
like there's
like what i hear in some of those
conversations from linda it's like
he wants to be respected he wants to be
submitted to whatever
but he's not taking actions that are
worthy of respect or submission and
anytime any man throws around you need
to submit to me because the bible says
that's a red flag right there could i
just say that because the men that you
want to follow are not men that are
throwing that around and it's not the
way that you
love and lead in a marriage using that
kind of language
punishing your wife i'm not going to
contribute to the fam family financially
because you're doing something i don't
like
okay there's and so i think that one of
the things that
even just as we're kind of talking about
this and it applies to lots of marriages
not just the unity piece and the
communication
piece but the respect piece respecting
that other person's voice
respecting their values being willing to
lean into the conflict and have the
conversation until you can get on the
same page versus i'm just going to do
whatever i want to don't make decisions
at the ramses
of size without being in agreement
and right at this moment we have a
decision that she and i
are not in agreement on and so when
we're not in agreement
what we do is nothing that's right you
know the other person's might be like
well too bad see you later i'm just
going to go do what i want to that's
it's such a healthy thing to sit in that
because it shows the person i love you
enough to work through this with you
because i want to do it with you
right then not with you i'm gonna wait
on you to catch up
yeah please i want you to see my side
please
but we just you know if there's a
charity and a ministry we're gonna give
to
one of us doesn't feel good about it we
don't until we do enough research or get
more options and
both of us either don't feel good about
it then or both of us start to feel good
about it
and then we can move forward but we have
to have agreement to move forward on
major financial decisions when you
don't you're going to struggle
financially yeah good hour christy well
done
thanks for having me james childs and
kelly in the booth well done
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money chris hogan
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
here on the air
we'll take your calls at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five yoon is with us in san
francisco hi yoon how are you
hi dave and chris um i'm a little bit
nervous so i'll just read from my note
um my husband and i are in our late 30s
and then baby step
seven we have a household income of
about 300k
um we'd like to buy a primary house with
cash but wanted to ask whether you had a
formula to calculate
how much we could spend as a percentage
of our net worth which is about 2
million
good for you so you guys have been
intentional
yoon how much have you all saved for a
down payment on the home
oh well we i mean um you would use some
of your two million dollar net worth
right uh so i would say about a million
of it is
in investments so i guess technically
not in retirement
right okay and you do not own a home
today
we do um it was a it was a
pre pre ramsey house um it's currently
being rented out and it's
long distance landlording and we're
trying to get rid of it that's a whole
another okay
all right cool yeah well what we have
found when we
when we have talked to uh we did a book
with chris
uh that he did call called everyday
millionaires where we studied
10 000 millionaires a lot of them were
in your range and uh
and so what we can draw from that is
what they did
uh and by and large they were somewhere
uh between on a two million dollar net
worth
they would be somewhere between 25 to 50
of their net worth would be in their
house
we did not find them with seven we did
not find people with two million dollar
net worth living in a million and a half
house though
that'd be three quarters that'd be 75
percent of your net worth in your house
that would be
unhealthy um and the other thing we
found was the larger your
net worth the smaller the percentage
of your net worth is in a house so in
other words if you got 100 million
dollar net worth you would not have
30 in your house you know that that
wouldn't make that'd be
weird it'd be a be a very small
percentage then
so uh in your case you make a lot of
money and you're young
and you're in freaking san francisco
expensive
so i i'm going to be at 50
or less of your net worth in your house
and that's that aligns with your million
dollars that you've gotten investments
so i could go up to a million dollars
pretty comfortably
because two years from now it won't be
fifty percent of your net worth anymore
three years from now five years from now
ten years from now
the rest of your net worth will grow now
your house value will grow but it won't
grow as fast as the rest of your nest
egg
because you got this huge income and
your big savers you've done a wonderful
job saving and investing
yeah and you're going to have to stomach
the idea of that dollar amount coming
out of your net worth right
i mean so yeah exactly coming out of the
investments to write the check so that's
the thing that i'd caution you on
is don't rationalize we'll get a
mortgage and we'll just pay it off fast
no no no go with this with cash and yoon
like you said this long distance
landlord plan that's that's a recipe for
a headache
you're getting rid of that i would get
that bad boy on the market and get it
sold uh and maybe you look at adding
that along with you know
what you're doing with your home so if
you went 750 to a million how does that
feel to you
it's a little scary honestly because we
want to have kids
at some point and you know um some point
soon actually in the near future
um and so i guess in my mind i'm you
know my husband's over here
talking as the spender he's talking
about wanting to buy a vacation home
eventually wanting to
do all this stuff and i just think uh
how much should we be saving
for you know children's
i guess future right now that's you guys
sitting there so wait a minute if you
if you quit and came home to be with
kids in the future how much of the 300k
income is you yeah yeah about half okay
all right and so in the future you might
be facing that
so that might that might cause you to
want to dial back from that then
but i you know again san francisco i
don't know where you are in that market
but they charge for air out there
it's uh the the um i mean enough people
have left california there's probably a
lot of houses on the market but
i mean the values are going to drop
eventually with all the um
all the people escaping yeah and so um
i mean there's a huge migration oh it's
out of there so
the numbers are astronomical all right
dave i'm gonna put you on the spot how
much
you're spending anyway so i e she's
saying she doesn't want to spend as much
as i gave her permission i know it
which is rare it's okay if you want to
dial back but i mean
i i'm just i don't know what you're
buying for a half million dollars in the
san francisco market
that's true you might be you might be i
mean that that's probably a median house
price there
yeah easily depending on which suburb
you're in now the husband's gonna have
to dial back and he's creating a wish
list not necessarily a to-do list
and so having a vacation home and doing
all these things
bless his heart he doesn't know what
kids do when they come on the scene they
cost money
and so have that conversation with
immune and make that list and that idea
and just do me the favor of this
whatever you do do it with cash yeah as
you guys are saving up because like dave
said you're amazing
savers i think you guys can reach that
and uh still live your dreams yeah so
somewhere between a half million and a
million and pay cash for the house just
the answer to your question
and that rental is on the market yeah
she's already done with it and whatever
equity you've got there is going to come
back to you too
obviously so that's going to be helpful
but
you're doing a really really good job
kiddo you're really doing well
excellent job open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five twenty twenty one is
almost
here i'm gonna have the biggest
new year's party just to say goodbye to
the dumpster fire year
what a horrible year it's been great in
a lot of ways i've had a lot of
wonderful things happen but it's just
nastiness everywhere and people oh
people people people people people be
nice
uh we've been through a lot this year
all of us have breathe
as you're preparing for christmas in the
new year spend time
enjoying who god is spend time enjoying
who you are
where you are where you're going christy
wright has written a brand new
devotional called
living true 40 days to get back to you
and it'll help you
rest reset and start feeling like you
again
our team is using every reason to give
stuff away you can now pick up our life
changing books and kids products about
ninety percent off during our week long
green monday sale and the proximity
principle
love your life not theirs audiobooks are
only three dollars the everyday
millionaire book by chris that we were
just discussing
is um ten dollar sale total money
makeovers ten dollar sale
so you could buy like a case of books 10
bucks or something
for 100 bucks and that takes care of a
lot of people stocking stuffers i'll
tell you
so visit the online store daveramsey.com
backslash store and you can get these
great deals be sure you are
checking on them and getting all that
lined up so chris um
you're now in my category all your books
are on sale for ten dollars it's a
little bit
it's a little bit um embarrassing yeah
we sell them for ten dollars i'm gonna
have to talk to you at the break about
that dave that's too low well mine are
that low
you can't you can't [ __ ] about it
well there's that there's the
conversation we just had that's a break
wait is this the dave ramsey chef
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com
will help you every step of the way just
like they've helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help
by phone and online plus they guarantee
the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air this is
the dave ramsey
show at triple eight eight two five five
two two five jackson's in denver
hi jackson how are you i'm doing well
dave hop with yourself
better than i deserve what's up
uh yeah so i had a question um so a
little background of
i'm a first generation or was a
first-generation college student um and
i've now found myself living
somewhat of a cliche rich class poor
lifestyle
um recently moved out of the bay area
now here in colorado
um and unfortunate enough to you know
land a pretty sought-after job in
finance
um you know and about four months ago i
recently purchased a car
and my question to you is you know i'm
paying about twenty three hundred
dollars in rent at the moment
and uh you know i realized i bit off way
more than i could chew
um considering my current income and you
know i have like you know
i've accrued about seven thousand
dollars in credit card debt
um so you know i i want to know if i'm
making the right decision
and downsizing and moving out of the
downtown area that i currently reside in
um and you know picking up a smaller
place uh currently and
keeping the car and currently making
payments on and just you know once kobe
da
once covet uh kind of you know gets out
of the picture i commute to work
okay and so what do you owe on the car
um i currently own about 21 000 left in
the car and what is your income
um so my my base about 65 and then my
bonus
is about 55 000 to 60.
okay and you have seven thousand dollars
in credit card debt
right how much student loan debt i'm
zero i
had eight internships and uh i had two
jobs for college that's paying off
okay you're not afraid of work that's
good okay
and um yeah 2300 is ridiculous in your
situation
you do need to move down and rent
because the
rent money that you're paying is forcing
your hand on other stuff and it's what's
caused the credit card debt
you didn't pay the rent with a credit
card but you gave all your money away to
rent and so you didn't have any money
when you went to buy something and you
used a credit card
because your house poor exactly
it's eating it's eating your lunch and
so i want you on the cheapest possible
thing
and then cut up the credit cards as soon
as you get off the phone
and uh and it will do that and attack
those cards and let's get let's get
let's get let's get moved
and let's get on a tight budget and uh
you working 40 hours
i'm working about 120 hours currently
wow
but no ot huh uh yeah no it's salary
based it's uh
it's a job in private equity yeah
okay well jackson i'll tell you this
buddy i i love the idea that you already
have the mindset of downsizing
that shows you willing to sacrifice but
here's the thing that i would be
concerned about
even if you downsize and you continue
the habits you're doing
you're going to continue to have credit
card debt you're going to continue to
have a car payment so
not only should you downsize but you
need a shift
in your in your mindset and just how
you're looking at money
it's got to be about cash buddy your
income is going to continue to go based
on your age you're making a heck of an
income and it's going to get bigger
what you've got to do is make sure that
you say if i don't have cash i'm not
doing it
right i just i'm not and so i want you
to go to zero and attack that credit
card debt then the car
and you say i'm not going backwards
anymore i mean think about what it feels
like to have absolutely no payments
right now and be living in a cheap place
and saving for your first house
yeah that that's really only about a
year away for you
if you completely start focusing on this
debt because he's got a serious work
ethic i mean
that that boy's going places yeah you're
gonna you're gonna be just fine sir
you're doing really well
yeah you're making good decisions gary
is in lexington hi gary how are you
i'm good dave how you doing better than
i deserve how can i help
all right i had a question a few years
ago i had
my grandparents had passed away and they
left
a piece of land a pretty significant
piece of land to me and my mother
and me and my wife had decided this year
to build a house somewhere else
we didn't want to live there we didn't
really like the community
and now we're kind of in the position to
where and my mom has taken care of like
all everything with it
all these years like even with taxes and
stuff
and we are kind of wanting to get away
from it we kind of want to
maybe sell our part and
i've talked with her a little bit about
it and i don't know if she
i don't think she wants to because she's
living in the house
that it's our house that's on the farm
as well
and i don't think she wants to sell it
and i don't know the process of morally
how to do
it without damaging anything
uh i just kind of want to know the
process of what would be the process to
get me started
how many acres it's about
65 acres it's a it's a big piece of land
yeah
so what would be wrong with just
planting it off and you guys take the
portion that's not improved and sold
that
and left her with 30 acres in the house
i've never thought about that i mean
she'd have plenty of room
she'd still be on the family ground yep
and you just sell off this
you know the you'd have to just figure
out how to configure it get it get a
an engineering firm to help you draw the
plot to where it's beneficial to your
mom
we want to protect her we want to
protect the memories
and the family as much as family
homestead as much as we can
and we want to create a a property line
configuration that gives her privacy
gives her a sense that something's not
built over on top of her
and that kind of a thing and you don't
even have to take exactly half you could
take less
okay be generous to her okay yeah i do
that
you could take 25 acres and she got 40.
yeah depending on how the configuration
works
yeah yeah i'd have to look into that
how receptive how do you think she'll
respond to that option
you know i think i never thought about
presenting it like that
yeah she would be okay with it because
she's i've lived there my whole life
until this year how much you do how much
road frontage
uh we are kind of off of like we're kind
of off of a main
like road uh and the way that it's laid
out though is there is like there's only
one entrance
into the property uh and i don't know
what the way the trust is laid out
because there always has to be like an
ease way into the property yeah i don't
have to be they don't know
that's going to affect your
configuration that i'm talking about
it's going to the more
road frontage you've got the more the
easier this idea is and it sounds like
you have no road frontage
and so you're going to be split you're
going to be giving an easement to the
new owner
near her house is what it amounts to
so now is this property tillable is it
being farmed or is it
wood is it timber what is it
it is probably about i think about 25
acres of it is cut
you know and then the rest of it is
emperor okay
and so uh and how far where is it
located in kentucky
yeah it's in kentucky we're we're just
south of lexington about 45 minutes in
like the london corbin area yeah yeah
beautiful beautiful area
yeah we love it yeah well so we just
moved there yeah
somebody might buy that almost as a
hunting camp yep
yeah yeah it's probably got some deer on
it yeah
and gary are you are you an only sibling
yes it was left to me and my mother okay
okay you know yeah well i i think that's
the way to look at it
um and that solves the problem and that
way you're not running her off the
property
which is going to be very difficult
yeah you can you can do it you can do it
legally but it's going to be emotionally
destructive
yeah yeah that's what i did not want to
do because
we have a great relationship and i don't
want to do anything as far as that i
guess the other pro
the other possibility is she having
money
she does not okay all right so she can't
buy you out
yeah that that that's what i was saying
but i know there's no way that she could
yeah okay right well i would tell you
this gary don't let this be a fly by
conversation
um i'd want you to really sit down
informally you know talk to your mom
acknowledge
what the land means and what it's meant
to you and want to honor her
and really help her understand this as a
business transaction like don't come in
as gary the son
just kind of come in and really present
it and lay it out
um and and and help her to begin the
process
i wouldn't expect her to give you an
answer on the spot give her some time to
process it
and then follow up with her in a day or
two yeah just ask a lot of questions and
give a lot of honor
yeah giving honor it doesn't cost a
thing
and it's appropriate in this situation
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're financially conscious you know
that healthcare expenses can take a big
bite out of your budget
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is here to help trim
those expenses and make sure your family
is cared for
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
most people have the means to pay for
basic doctor services but
when it comes to something on a much
larger scale say
several thousand dollars for surgery or
hospitalization
folks are worried they'll be left to try
and find a way to pay for that
themselves
not too long ago i was diagnosed with
ovarian cancer
and they really came through so far
we've had over 180 thousand dollars
worth of bills
and got close to 75 discounts chm shared
the rest of the expenses
to see if chm is right for you and your
budget
check out chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
aaa 825-5225
if you're still looking for great
christmas deals our team is using every
reason they can to give stuff away
you can knock off up to about 90 off of
a whole bunch of items at our
green monday sale that's going on all
week our famous ten dollar sale is still
here you can get any of our number one
best-selling books
for ten dollars each stock up on the
books that'll help you and your loved
ones get out of debt plan for retirement
become an everyday millionaire
visit the online store daveramsey.com
petra is with us in jackson wyoming hi
petra how are you
good how are you doing better than i
deserve
how can we help um so me and my husband
and our
daughter we are on baby steps four five
and six
and my question is basically about
housing
so jackson is super expensive to live in
and
right now we are looking into
buying something and we kind of have
three different options that we're
looking at
we could buy an affordable home um
in jackson but with that we would
there's a lot of rules that go with that
so you don't really have much control
about housing
or your unit um so we we don't really
like that
we were looking into buying a home that
would be
um an hour away from jackson and
commuting which is what a lot of people
do
but then we're looking into spending
more money on gas
it would be a little bit harder for me
to find a job
and because i am a stay-at-home mom and
the last one was we would which is what
we liked the most
is we would stay in jackson and we would
continue to rent and we were looking
into
all the money that we having um saved up
right now um then money would be
increasing
um so with the difference in gas
and the increase we would be able to
save some too even though we're spending
money on the rent so i didn't know what
would be
the right decision and i'm kind of
looking for love guidance
uh you don't have to move an hour
outside of jackson to get rid of
restrictions
um well that we can afford they sell
homes in jackson too it's just we can't
afford them
yeah but i mean you said the
restrictions were too much is what you
didn't like
um if we so they have like a housing
opportunity in town
that um they will sell units at the
affordable housing for the
workforce i guess yeah um but you can
afford these just they'll put
um restrictions on like let's say you're
high i don't disagree with you i would
do that what's your household income
um we're at about 65 okay
and so it does not require it does
require
to get the price down that you get
outside of jackson been to jackson hole
skiing many times been
been to jackson many times wonderful
town
you're right it's a it is a resort price
range and there's a shortage of labor
and all kinds of things so um but you
you don't have to move an
hour away to get the price down
well we could so we could do 30 minutes
but even those
housing units are going for um if you
look at
our income it's still going for the
higher what we would like
yeah i don't believe you
i don't think you've gone shopping
enough because see here's the thing
what you're presenting to me are three
options and none of them are good
and so i'm going with d none of the
above
you know an hour commute is no fun
renting is no fun
and restrictive housing in worker hou or
restricted
mess and uh quote affordable housing for
workers is no good
so we've got to just keep searching to
find another option anytime i'm going to
make a bad
make a decision and all my options are
bad guess what i'm getting ready to make
a bad decision that's right
and so you've gotta you've gotta have
more options you're gonna have to i
don't know how we're gonna skin the cat
exactly but some way
we gotta get his fur off i mean there's
gotta be another way of doing this right
and one of the options is looking at and
figuring out how to a get your income up
or eight you continue to rent while you
guys continue to save
or you look at relocating i mean i you
know in looking at this i'm gonna begin
to make a decision
based on the information i have and so i
want you to connect with a real estate
agent
and have them do some leg work for you
so you can start to understand what
those options really look like
because driving an hour each way you you
might be
okay with that for a couple of months
but that's going to get old yeah yeah
no that's i'm not i'm not signing up for
that not in that in that situation
hey thanks for the call i think you need
more options i do and i looked it up
dave the
the uh the median home price in jackson
wyoming
is 1.6 million in 2020
uh trending up 23 year-over-year
that's astronomical i've been to jackson
i've been to casper i've been to
riverton wyoming
uh this is on another level well that's
picking up the res that's picking up the
resort prices
right up around the ski slopes okay and
that's driving that way up
i got you down in town that would not be
true yeah my goodness
yeah i i can't i don't i can't believe
it's true i that's
that's like eight times the national
average yeah it's wyoming
well you know it's jackson i mean it's a
resort town yeah it's so you can have
you're gonna have a higher
uh thing i mean it but but yeah there's
something skewing that number
that number's off uh i think anyway
all right open phones a triple eight
eight two five five
two two five michael is in washington dc
hey michael how are you hey how you
doing dave great how can we help
i have a question um i've been following
you for like maybe now maybe eight
months
and i did the snowball effect i paid off
all my debt all my bills except one good
um i paid off like maybe twenty four
thousand dollars worth of debt
wow good for you yeah thank you thank
you now i have a car it's a two thousand
and it's 2016 electric
rc coupe 300 i traded in another car to
get it so i
you know like kind of in a hole so it's
worth 42
000 no i owe 42 000 it's only worth
28 000 that's my only debt
i bring home i work two jobs so i bring
home 4 500
a month so my question is you think i
and my credit is pretty good now i have
no credit cards i cut them up so my
question is you think i said
sell my car and get a loan or pay the
difference or
just go through this as well i'd plow
through it
yeah if those numbers are right you're
screwed you're so far in the hole
that's selling the car you're still
gonna have thirty thousand dollars in
debt when you sell it and no car
yeah here's the thing 24 000 you did in
one year right
yes so two more years of doing that
you're out of this thing
correct okay that's why i was calling up
because i was thinking of
if i sell it then i would only be i owe
43
is worth 26 27. so that would give me
like
15 17 000 to pay off with no car but
but well i i think you just get that you
know what you might want to do is pay it
down to where you're at break even and
then sell it
okay okay but in the meantime drive it
and just keep chunking because
i mean if you're if you're dropping debt
at 24k a year that's 2 000
a month right then you're gonna yeah in
eight or ten months you're gonna have
this car paid down to even then you
could sell it
and and then buy something really super
cheap pay cash for it
and then save up and move up in car as
you finish up your emergency fund yeah
michael take all the money you were
paying out on the other debt
as you were working the snowball and now
direct that money toward this car
and it's going it's going to take you a
minute uh but here's what i learned when
i did my stupid many years ago
uh pd as pre dave i had the suv payment
and it had was 750 dollars a month which
is lord clean stupid i know don't don't
do that i
already had a flashback uh but chill the
bottom line is
is once you work and you pay that off
each and every payment you make
it's more confirmation of the lesson
never again
and so that frustration and irritation
as you stroke that check
that's what will make sure that you're
never in this position again
yeah i think it's going to take you
about 10 months to get out of this thing
yeah
and i think that's probably the best
route um
much much easier than trying to sell it
while it's upside down
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yes
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five daniel
is in salt lake
hi daniel how are you i'm doing great
how are you guys
better than i deserve how can we help
thanks so much for taking my call
um got a couple questions me and my um
my wife we make
around a hundred thousand dollars a year
um
we have no credit card debt no student
loan debt
we have a car payment of um
or the total is about fourteen thousand
dollars um
but my problem is i am in january i am
i'm leaving my job to go to uh school
full-time
so i'm going to be taking a huge pay cut
and probably just working like two days
a week
so and we all have also have probably
about 90
000 in cash um in my bank
so i'm trying to think what is the best
option
like right now should i just pay off my
wife's car um
just for the full cash even though we're
taking probably a forty thousand dollar
pay cut for this year
because you're taking your 40 000 pay
cut yeah stroke
check today yeah not not not even though
but because you are
you pay it off today okay or sell it one
of the two
yeah yeah it's got to go yeah we should
yeah okay so what are you what are you
doing what are you going back to school
for
uh biology i'm gonna try to go into um
wildlife management or um
wildlife biologist or something it's
just something i've always wanted to do
and
i've been working in the hotel industry
for my whole life and it's been fun it's
been you know it's made me good money
and
made a living off of it but it's just
i'm kind of ready to go do something
that i really enjoy
so what's your wife make uh she makes
this year she's getting close to 60. she
owns her own photography business
and she's done really well just the past
three years that she keeps making more
so she's
she's doing she's doing really well
wonderful
and and so you're going to pay for
school out of the 90
correct okay and and cover living
expenses shortfalls if there are any
but i think you need to adjust i don't
think there need to be any i think you
need to adjust your lifestyle to be
within her income
right do you all have kids daniel
no sir okay because my question would be
this i mean i i love the idea that you
have this wildlife
thought and you want to go down that
path but why not work and go to school
at night
and knock out some of these
prerequisites uh
at a community college for much cheaper
and then transfer that to a four-year
institution
he's in the hotel business even working
right now anyway oh hey i think i i
think i will
like you know maybe after the semester
it's just been you know i'm 30 years old
so it's been a while since i've been to
college and i'm going back to college so
i'm kind of just starting off slow
i probably maybe by the end of the year
i could i could bump up my work schedule
it's just kind of a scary thought taking
a pay cut
one other thing too so i'm going to pay
off my car
i years ago probably i don't know 2014
um i probably spent fifteen hundred
dollars
on buying bitcoin um and i probably made
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
off of it um so i it was
it was such a small amount i just i like
i bought it and i just
left it and i never did anything with it
um i know it's very risky and everything
but i didn't really put anybody into it
um what do you guys what do you guys
think about that
is are you saying you can cash it out
today for a hundred grand
for sure okay so by not okay
listen to me just a second okay there's
a process in finance called sunk
cost analysis all right and so if you
don't cash it out today
in the morning you have reinvested a
hundred thousand dollars into bitcoin
should scare your brains out
it's not 1500 it's a hundred thousand
every day you leave it there you are
reinvesting
the end of this again right
by nightfall dude cash it
okay bitcoin is going over 50 of your
freaking net worth
is on the roulette table
on one roll of the dice it's in code
yeah if you if you really can cash it
out and
you may find out that this is funny
money but i hope you can
i hope you can too and run stream run
away
run away yeah you know um
i you know this is one of those things
you guys where
again you're hearing about this stuff
out there and it sounds too good to be
true
it is and you got to be careful you
really do
i've talked to a lot of people that have
been burned on this and unfortunately
have gone the route of even leveraged
investing schemes
which is pulling money out of their
house to invest which is an absolute no
no
and so just be smart do long-term
investing
whenever you try to get rich quick what
i found is you end up getting broke
fast and so you want to have a mindset
of building wealth over time you know
the
i i hope that you can cash it out when
you go to do it tonight
i'm suspect when i hear 1500 turns into
100 000 i'm really suspect that you that
you're getting
um i i hope you can
i hope you can i'll just leave it at
that i hope you don't find other things
when you go try to cash it out
um but those numbers are are bizarre
and um and if it if you are able to cash
it out the
other danger is isn't that you actually
pulled off this crap once and it's going
to tempt you to do it again
so um but you do whatever you want to do
but i i am not a fan of ultra high risk
investments
and uh at a minimum that's what we would
call bitcoin
at a minimum we could call it a lot of
other stuff too a whole lot of things
but um yeah and also an alternative
currency well even if it is an
alternative currency
i don't buy currencies well and the
other side is if you can't do that the
other phone call you need to make is to
a tax elp
uh so you can understand the realized
gain on that
because you are going to deal with uncle
sam on the growth and
again you know i think daniel you
walking through the process and being
very intentional
with this and on the other side too with
this wildlife thing that you're wanting
to pursue
i want you to have a burning passion for
it not just be interested in it
because you're about to take a whole
nother shift in life uh
and i hope you're not doing that just to
get away from the hotel industry uh
there are a lot of things that you can
do without making this kind of lifestyle
change
yeah yeah that's um that's true open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five nebraska's on the line
logan
is calling hey logan what's up hey good
afternoon mr ramsey mr elgin thanks for
taking my call sure how can we help
thanks to you guys my wife and i we're
29-27 we're on baby step 7.
way to go we're just having a lot of fun
so thank you for your teaching and
for god's wisdom thank you um my
question today and i come at it from two
different angles
one as an individual and the second as a
coordinator
i work with a lot of farmers and i have
farmed in the past as well
my question is how in the world do you
get started farming or
yeah how do you get started farming
without so much
debt and then as a coordinator my
question is how do i help
those farmers who are in massive amounts
of debt
slowly start to get their way out well
that's exactly how you do it
slowly you're going to get out a little
bit at a time and you the the problem is
that with most farmers is they have just
accepted like with a lot of small
business people
they've just accepted that the only way
to do it is debt yep
and then they get real mad dave ramsey
doesn't understand farming well yes i do
i understand
business and i understand what a 500 000
freaking tractor looks like too and so i
get it i understand i'm sitting in a 70
million dollar building that i paid cash
for
so the uh doing this broadcast from a
studio that cost millions of dollars
so the yeah i understand large capital
purchases in order to do business
did i start there no so if i was
starting out farming today
and i said okay i'm not gonna borrow
money how am i gonna do it well i'm
gonna do it with a cheap
used old piece of crap tractor and i'm
gonna pay cash for it and i'm gonna
lease
somebody's land because i don't have the
money to buy the land
and by the way that's how i started this
business i started with
using somebody else's studio and i
rented
our office space until we could save up
and pay cash for it
and i didn't accept the idea of the only
way you can do real estate is with that
don't accept the premise yeah this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host chris hogan
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
we're taking your calls about your life
and your money common sense
for your dollars and cents teaching you
to live on less than you make a concept
congress can't grasp
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two
five jim is in tulsa oklahoma
with our question first question of the
hour hey jim how are you
i am great thank you dave and chris for
taking my call uh
my wife and i have become deca
millionaires and they've been very
blessed and fortunate we have no
children
and we have two nieces and a nephew
that we're not terribly close to but
they're in their 20s and good people a
school teacher
manages a restaurant those sorts of
things but they are
certainly not ready to uh have multiple
millions of dollars dumped on them we've
already
funded our foundation and things and we
were wondering the
you know just what you guys thought
regarding whether it's appropriate to
reach out to them
and say guys you want to you know
undergo a little teaching and learning
and i don't want to micromanage what
would you do if
suddenly you got several million dollars
what would be the plan for your life
because without that we just feel like
it'd be giving them a loaded gun
well jim you're absolutely right buddy
congratulations first and foremost on
you all working very hard being
intentional
uh and and truly building a new legacy
i agree with you i think you've got
every opportunity to be able to use this
as a learning lesson
for them to go through financial peace
university for them to begin to
understand
the things that you've learned and
really treating it as such um you know
believe it or not you you have the
ability to put any kind of criteria on
here that you want
you know as you look at this and the way
we view it is it's the lord's money
you've been blessed and a good to be a
good steward of it and so being a good
steward would be teaching them
and guiding them and making sure they're
prepared uh to be able to handle this
stuff the right way
money when it comes to folks and you've
experienced this gym and so have i so is
chris
whether it comes quickly or whether it
comes slowly
it magnifies the person
it makes you more of what you already
are if you have problem with anger
you become a tyrant if you have a
integrity you get extremely concerned
about integrity
you know if you're kind and generous you
become outlandishly generous
and so that'll happen to them the good
parts of their character will be
magnified the bad parts of their
character will be magnified it happens
to all of us
money's a magnifier that's what it does
money doesn't make you
have problems you've already had
problems it just
magnifies them your marriage is weak you
get a big pile of money it'll end your
marriage
you know and so you're exactly right the
loaded gun
is a good metaphor here you're handing a
loaded gun to someone who's never pulled
a trigger before
that is a scary thing so yeah we don't
want to micromanage i don't want to tell
them i don't want a micromanager i just
don't get shot
yeah exactly so exactly so and you know
and obviously
by the time they would inherit this we
wouldn't be around and i
i do think some kind of a trust may be
an order or something absolutely
and you know if they aren't comfortable
with it or we're not comfortable with
them
i'm okay saying uh you know have a great
life and do your thing
yeah we love you and good luck and hope
everything works out well i don't you
know i don't accept your conditions
well you don't really have a choice
right the only way you get the money is
with the conditions
so because i'm concerned for you
that this not be a problem for you but
instead is a blessing
right and jim i've talked to people that
have had laid out some stipulations for
their kids
and if the kids don't abide by that then
they've also designated a charity that
would be the recipient
or multiple charities that would be the
recipient or an amount going to the
church and so
i think you can have that primary and
educate them but you and your wife also
have that back-up plan
but you also said something that's
crucial you reserve the right to make
changes
and that you do yeah absolutely and i
think it's the
it's it's the kindest way to do this and
your
your spirit is not one of overt
control freak your spirit is just one of
concern yeah
and if they if they interpret that as
overt control freak that could just that
alone could be a disqualifier
i mean i i think back of we're
62 and 61. now i think back when i was
20 something if somebody had given me
this amount of money
without an extreme amount of guidance it
would have been a train wreck
it would have been yeah and we never
would have accomplished
the things we've been blessed to do
exactly i mean i always tell folks you
know
one of the metaphors i use when i'm
teaching on this is it's uh you know
my son comes in he's 14 years old dad i
want to buy a brand new corvette
so my first car when i'm 16 and i'm like
no i've seen you drive you're
incompetent
you're going to get an old chevette with
a gerbil under the under the hood you
know
and so and then when you prove when you
are faithful in the little things
then you'll be given more to manage and
that's what scripture says right
and so yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna say you
know
we're getting ready to give you a
corvette but
you're gonna kill yourself with the
thing if you don't get driving lessons
and they have no idea
i mean they i'm guessing our families
think we have
you know a couple of million dollars or
a little more than that they have no
idea that
you know you put a zero on that and um
and it's you know and you know we have a
sizable foundation that
does a lot of things but uh so jim if
you work all your life you get to be the
rich uncle that everybody wanted
yeah i think so i guess i i just thought
of that you're the rich uncle everybody
wants oh this is great
and we uh you know i
i just uh you know you only get one
chance to handle this right and by the
time it goes wrong you're you're in
heaven already and i just don't want to
mess that up
yeah i think you sit down with them and
you begin the uh
the process of discussing this and say
you know
would you like us to show you how to
handle money so that we feel comfortable
live leaving you some and if you would
like
that person if you would like that
that's not a control freak thing it's i
don't want to hand
someone who's never driven a car the
keys to a brand new corvette
with it with a 500 horsepower engine
under the hood i just don't want to do
that it's not
wise for you it's going to be harmful
for everybody
including all of us driving around you
at what point would you reveal the
actual numbers
uh pretty early if they if they if they
are open you know it depends on their
if you get a receptive spirit right but
if you got somebody that's rebellious
and just throws their back up then
you know first you're gonna know that in
one conversation or two
yeah you know you know they're not gonna
decide oh
i'm not gonna be a jerk based on the
numbers they're just going to show you
that they're jerk right
or they're going to go yes i would be
honored to have someone that has built
wealth show me how to build wealth
and manage wealth i mean what a gift
yeah it is a gift and jim i hope you and
your wife are enjoying it and doing all
kinds of things now
and giving to some charities now so
you've got a big foundation yes
like that is amazing buddy enjoy it good
job con congratulations
very much well done very well done love
it
[Music]
good live like no one else so later you
can live and give
like no one else this is the dave ramsey
[Applause]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money
we've got about 967 people on our team
right now
and over a hundred and fifty of them are
on our creative
team alone we got a lot of creatives in
the building
uh we act as actually one big in-house
agency
that supports all the business units
inside ramsey
and our team is currently looking for
some product designers with
strong visual design skills and a
background in user experience and user
research if you've been impacted by this
mission and you want to spread this
message of hope
with your creative talents well apply
for a position here
find out about all the available jobs at
daveramsey.com
careers we'll hire about 250 people in
the coming 12 months
and so all kinds of different positions
but certainly
a bunch will be in the creative and in
the technology fields
and we're really doing work that matters
we were voted
one of the best places to work in the
united states
by inc magazine last year so apply today
at daveramsey.com
slash careers check out all the jobs but
certainly the creative ones
all right brittany is i'm sorry corey is
with us in phoenix hi corey welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hey dave how are you doing today better
than i deserve man what's up
um i just i was gonna ask you about
cryptocurrency but i i think i kind of
got where you stand on that from your
last
call glass caller asked about it but um
i'm a small business owner i've been
following you guys uh
for you specifically for i don't know
five or seven years
um i don't have any any debt on 32 years
old
and i was just curious as far as as
like for a business as far as working
with terms with your suppliers
or like you know not 30 not 60 if you
include that as as debt or credit or if
you see that as the necessary part of
doing business
just because i'm just i don't want to
take on debt necessarily but
sometimes i just struggle to to get the
materials and stuff like that
for certain jobs you know yeah well i
mean depending on how you're doing the
job you can take enough deposit up front
to cover materials and keep things
moving
we i mean certainly companies we do a
lot of business with all kinds of
vendors and they bill us and we pay them
but we don't uh sign up for or take
product or services off of a vendor if
we don't have the money to pay them
and hope it works out that would be debt
even if it is a net 30. now
uh we clear our if we have an invoice
come in
this week during the week and it matches
with a po that was already in place in
our accounting system
we will clear it on tuesday morning
so we pay you inside of seven days uh
we don't ride people for 30 days and
that kind of stuff now it has to match
up and it has to be an accurate invoice
and sometimes it takes a little while to
get all that stuff done
but if it hits our system our accounting
system and it matches
we pay it almost instantaneously
and so but it yeah i technically i owe
them money
but technically i owe the guy that cuts
my grass money after he cuts my grass
and he sends me a bill and i pay him
you know it's the same thing i pay i pay
the day i get the bill
and uh within a day or two of getting
the bill so it's not it's not
different than that uh but i don't
um you know take a uh
a vendors services or wares
and hope it all works out and i can pay
them yeah because that that sets you up
for problems then then you are using
them as a bank
yeah and corey i want to invite you to
get over to our entree leadership uh go
to entreleadership.com
uh inside of that that's really where
we're walking with business owners and
leaders
uh and really helping them not only
inside of running the business but also
with the people portion and inside of
that we talk about retained earnings
uh which becomes really the thing that
as a business owner you're wanting to
make sure you're setting aside
some of the earnings so later you become
your own bank you become your own safety
net as you're running your business
and chris i'll circle back around on the
uh cryptocurrency question again
i don't teach people to invest
in volatile investments
that are high risk right and so i
wouldn't have you invest
in the dollar as a currency
i wouldn't have you invest in the pound
the yen as a currency the peso as a
currency
you can play currencies like you play
commodities
and you can play cryptocurrency like you
play commodities
now if you play commodities you can make
you know you put in five thousand
dollars and make 50 grand
i mean you make 10x in a matter of few
weeks um or you can put in 5 000
and get nothing and that's pretty much
the same thing with cryptocurrency or
playing play in the currency market i
don't play currency markets
the people that are doing cryptocurrency
are doing it for one of two reasons
they are either trying to get rich quick
and they think it's going to go through
them to the moon
and they think they're going to make a
ton of money and they might they might
just like if you played a commodity just
like if you put the money on a football
game
i mean you could go to you know one of
the betting services
and bet ten to one odds and you know you
could get rich quick
i mean you could but you could lose it
all too and these are high risk
endeavors right
it's it is truly a gamble more than an
investment yeah and i don't really do
gambling
with money it's too hard to come by i
invest when something
steady and predictable the second reason
people do cryptocurrency is
they're all enamored with the the uh
philosophy of it
that it's outside of regulatory
guidelines
and there's no nothing no it you know
it's kind of a a libertarian thing of i
can go do what i want to do off the
grids
except except that you're actually more
on the grid than you've ever been in
your life when you're doing this stuff
but
uh but but i mean it's this idea that
it's outside the purview of
nations and governments to control it
and it's kind of got its own little
thing out here its own ethos that it can
run
in and they love that idea and that's
all fine i you know i can't believe dave
ramsey is as
libertarian freedom as you are that you
don't support cryptocurrency i don't
support it because it's a bad
it's a high risk investment and i don't
put i don't tell people put money in
something i don't put money in
there it is and so that's the thing i
just don't do it
right and it's a and
the problem is when you get to chasing
get rich quick
people they get the fever
and they stop using critical thinking
skills
and then they become very defensive as
if it's not
a high risk investment because in their
mind they had to push that that
high risk aside in order to make the
play that's right
to be able to rationalize they had to
put put it behind the wall yes
and so because it's behind the wall then
anyone who says cryptocurrency is a bad
idea
then they're evil and when i you know so
all the cryptocurrency
guys hate me and there's white websites
dave ramsey's wrong
dave ramsey's wrong dave ramsey's wrong
no yeah no i'm not
um you know and same thing with the gold
guys oh yeah you know we tell people not
to buy gold gold silver
we tell people not to my whole life
those guys don't like us we tell people
not to lease cars those guys don't like
us
but all we're concerned about is you
people we're just trying to help you
and so you know you can you can go and i
i don't you know you can go and put a
hundred thousand dollars or fifteen
thousand dollars or ten thousand dollars
or two thousand dollars
on the table on blackjack table and you
can do that
or you can bet it on a football game if
you want you can play high-risk stuff if
you want to it's your money you get to
decide
but you're listening to me because i
have chris has
data and decades of experience
that show you how to become wealthy yeah
and do it the right way and do it in a
way that you don't put your family at
risk you don't put your future at risk
you don't put your health at risk
um it is just really one of those this
recipe is a plan that works
and in looking at that you know people
work hard for money
the last thing i'm going to do is put it
on something like a cryptocurrency
that is decentralized has no regulations
uh
if you have convinced yourself that
commodities or day trading or
cryptocurrency
or blackjack is a sure thing because you
got a system
then what you have done is you put your
emotions and your critical thinking
skills behind an emotional wall
so that you can accept this and do it
but you've you've screwed yourself in
the process
you know now i i've got a relative that
loves to play
uh poker and he loses like everybody
does
when you're playing poker um you know
and so he'll go
to vegas and lose you know four thousand
dollars five thousand dollars or
whatever on a weekend
and he has a great time and for him
that's recreation and he just budgeted
that to spend
right and so he but he didn't see it as
a way to
become wealthy right right but he enjoys
the card game
right and he's budgeted for it i don't
get that but he does
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com
will help you every step of the way just
like they've helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help
by phone and online plus they guarantee
the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
marilee is with us hi marilee how are
you hey dave i'm doing great how are you
doing
better than i deserve where do you live
uh actually we're from dalton georgia
okay well that's not too bad a run up to
nashville no
but welcome and you're here to do a
debt-free scream yes sir
how much have you paid off 29 000.
wow how long did this take 20 months
good for you
and your range of income during that
time it was 28 000.
okay what do you do for a living i'm
actually an analyst at a private
university
okay cool very good oh so what caused
this to happen merrily
why did you wake up all of a sudden and
say enough's enough it's got to get out
of here
well actually it was all student loans
and so whenever i graduated
i looked at how much i owed and i
thought that's a big number
and but i didn't think too much about it
and so i moved out on my own
and lived there for about a year in an
apartment and one day i was going to go
to work but it was raining outside and
so i
decided to turn on the windshield wipers
but they didn't work and so i took it to
a repair shop
and it was going to be 300 to get new
windshield wiper motors
yes wipers have motors yes they do
they do yes they do and so 300
was something that i could pay for but
it was actually
uh a lot for me and i thought this is
big you know
if i claim that i can live on my own
and be financially stable then why is
300 such a big deal to me
so that was a big deal but then shortly
after about a year
of living on my own my lease was up in
my apartment and then
i realized i'm living in an unsafe area
of town
so i decided to move back to my parents
house for about a month or two and then
i was walking in the woods and just
talking to the lord and
walking the dog and god brought out the
the idea of
just paying off my student loans and i
said you know what what are you talking
about like
that's so much money i don't know if i
could do that and still live at my
parents house for a while and uh
you know he said back you know merely i
know you can do this because you've got
grit and that was the first idea of
thinking like maybe it is possible and
so
um i went home and i talked to my mom
about the idea and
of course she was on board she loves me
so
and so yeah um once she said it was okay
um decided to well that was right
whenever everyday millionaires released
and so i read that book cover to cover
and that really started lighting the
fire oh yeah
and so from there i just created a
little timeline and it was going to be
august
of 2020 and then it ended up being june
with all the momentum that carries up
with it yeah why did it go yeah thank
you
how's it feel amazing it feels like
genie from aladdin at the very end
whenever
aladdin shows the lamp to genie and he
says genie you're free and then the
shackles fall off and
he doesn't know what to do so that it
feels a lot like that
it's just that moment of true freedom
yeah wow
very cool very cool all right so we've
got how old are you
i am 29 today hey well happy birthday
thank you yes so
27 year old is listening to us right now
yeah you do this in 20 months and
they're saying i wonder if i should do
this
what do you tell them and how do you
tell them that you got out of debt
what's the secrets
oh yeah the biggest thing is just start
with your foundation you know
why do you want to get out of debt uh do
you want to reduce stress do you want to
start building a legacy are there people
coming up behind you
that you want to be able to support and
then also um don't be afraid to get your
hands dirty you know just take on
whatever side job you can i
i worked every side hustle i could think
of that
would just give me a little bit of extra
cash over time cool what was your most
productive the the
side hustle that made you the most money
uh definitely cleaning a chiropractic
office twice a month
ah okay that'll work yeah oh yeah
uh and then also uh helping teach dance
in the evenings at a local dance studio
okay very good yeah yeah and then
the last thing is just making sure that
you have a community driven outlet you
know because
setting a goal like this is just not for
me it's not attainable by myself so i
needed a community and that's what i
would encourage for anybody else i mean
i had a
unity dance troupe in cleveland and we
would go there and rehearse weekly for
fall and spring productions
and that i had people walking
through the debt free journey with me
starting day one and
carried all the way through to the
finish line and i'm super thankful for
every single one of them there
they did amazing what happens when you
get some people around you yeah
you know it they it just helps you stay
motivated uh
and you can look to them even when you
get tired right and get your momentum
back oh yeah
oh yeah they were definitely with me
whenever life happened and
they were also with me whenever the
highs happened as well the really joyous
moments
yeah way to go proud of you so you
brought mom with you to cheer you on
i did yeah right very good very good
well um mom was obviously a cheerleader
yeah they were obviously cheerleaders
you got to have cheerleaders in the
corner it's not good that man be alone
exactly you know we're not designed for
that we're designed to be in community
that's why we've got it tied into remzy
plus and
into financial peace university to make
it all part of that so and the youtube
chat
yeah yeah there's nobody alone there
most people will follow you home oh my
gosh way to go i'm so proud of you
thank you well done hero you took
control of your life and on your
birthday you're doing your debt-free
scream
yes a lot of dignity in this well done
very very well done how does it feel
amazing yeah
good for you mm-hmm all right merrily we
got a copy you've already got chris's
book
she read it dave covered the cover oh
there you go
millionaire all right we'll give you
another book you just tell cat what you
want
whatever you want out there you can have
one of them that's all good very cool
well thank you for coming all the way to
nashville to share with us
a very good job i was so excited to come
merrily
from dalton georgia 29 000
paid off in 20 months making 28 a year
man it's impressive count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one i'm dead
i love it
well done our question of the day comes
from blinds.com you can find out why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping new
promos all the time
i always use the promo code ramsey to
get the best
deal all right today's question comes
from andrew in north dakota
he says i'm 20 years old and i'm working
on baby step three
i was wondering if it would be smart to
pull money from a non-retirement account
which is invested in mutual funds its
current value is four thousand
i have twenty five hundred saved up so
far and my goal
is eight thousand well in looking at
this andrew you don't tell me what your
income is
uh so as a couple schools of thought
here you could cash flow it
right and leave the mutual funds alone
and get there and get your emergency
fund built up
or based on income if it's too tight
then you could cash it out
uh and looking at this it would depend
on income flow
uh i'd like to leave those mutual funds
there and let them grow if at all
possible
yeah i i think he's not going to be able
to because he's got a small emergency
fund
yeah goal eight thousand dollars so that
tells me his income's low it's tight
yeah so i'm thinking you use it besides
that andrew you should have already
cashed it out
when you started the process yeah any
non-retirement money you've got of any
kind it should have been used for baby
steps
one through three from the first moment
you started on this process
and so yeah i i see a couple of reasons
there to go ahead and cash it out i love
investing like chris said leaving it
alone i think that'd be wonderful but
i i kind of smell in these numbers that
you need to do this
yeah and uh you needed it it needs to be
in an emergency fund not in a mutual
fund you'll get to your mutual fund
investing later
and you don't use mutual funds for
your emergency fund because that's right
here's the thing emergency funds are not
investments
they're insurance and insurance costs
you money to protect
the things that makes you money and
that's what this is
so the emergency runs not designed to
make you rich
it's designed to protect the things that
are going to make you rich like not
cashing out your 401k to fix your
transmission
because you had an emergency fund that's
right and you want to keep it liquid
and just in a money market account so
you can get to it but here's job one you
guys
if you end up using it thank goodness
you had it but job one becomes to
replace it
you always want to keep that amount in
there yeah very well done yes
good stuff this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
our scripture today hebrews 10 35 36
therefore do not throw away your
confidence which has a great reward
for you have need of endurance so that
when you have done the will of god
you may receive what is promised
helen keller said never bend your head
always hold it
high look the world straight in the eye
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money
right in front of you tracy is with us
next
in green bay wisconsin hi tracy welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hi how are you great how can we help
um so i have about a hundred thousand
dollars in
student loans um that i've had on a
ibr income base for repayment plan for
the last 13 years
translation you're getting nowhere right
um and the reason why
well i was raising four children by
myself and now i have one
to the last one who will be leaving the
nest soon
um but anyways um
so i have seven years left on this ivr
and i was just wondering i i have paid
off about
uh forty two thousand dollars in the
last three years
of debt and i was wondering now
where i should fit the student loans in
and it is
one fully consolidated student loan it's
not
a bunch of multiple little ones what's
your income
um about 56 000 okay
all right and the last one's leaving the
nest
yes okay well um if i woke up in your
shoes how old are you
uh 43 okay if i woke up in your shoes
and it was me knowing what i know now
here's what i would do
i would increase the intensity
with which you're budgeting
really tight budget on paper in great
detail
i want your budget super detailed every
month
every dollar has a name before the month
begins
and then squeeze it and i'm going to
increase my income
i'm going to pick up some extra income
from somewhere doing something
tutoring whatever it is i don't care
what it is and
and then i'm going to pay this off in
about three years
okay 33 000 a year for three years and
you're done
okay you're a survivor mama bear
yeah yeah it just feels like i've been
on this road for
so long yeah and it's time to get off of
it it's time to finish it now
yeah you have you focused on everything
else but this that's right
because you had to raise kids and you
did everything else now it's time to
punch this thing in the nose
yeah okay and tracy you did this as a
single mom
of four you've walked that you have
given those
kids what they needed and now it's time
to focus on your financial future yeah
you need to get free
you do and i want to tell you job well
done yeah your kids
uh but now we are all doing well they're
they're all successful
you know right so none of them
the point is the point is it's time for
that it's time for you to give
yourself the gift of freedom yes and
that's going to require
deep deep sacrifice and you're going to
go crazy
and you're going to sacrifice and you're
going to go nuts but for the first time
in a long long time it's going to be all
about you
yes and dave i'm going to tell you you
know her something else she needs
boundaries
she's going to have to with these kids
to not make sure that they're not trying
to reach back and trying to ask for
something else
to really have a finely clear boundary
on you focusing on this student loan
debt
and you focusing on self tracy hold on
i'm going to have kelly put you into
ramsey plus and sign you up for
financial peace university and
the every dollar app and the baby steps
tracker app we're going to give you all
the tools you need to do this
i predict you're out of debt in two and
a half years if you do what i'm talking
about
and for the first time in a long time
you're going to feel free
well done you're going to get there
we're going to help you we'll walk with
you
claire is in greenville south carolina
hi claire welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um so i'm a little nervous i've listened
to you for years and this is the first
time i've ever
called in um my husband and i
have about four thousand dollars of
medical bills that we've accrued this
year
and we've paid off five thousand dollars
already
good um so we're trying to
pay off the remaining four thousand and
we can't seem to get ahead on it so
we wanted to call in and see what you
suggest
you can't seem to get what we can't seem
to get um
pay off our medical bills oh you can't
find the money you're in the middle of
pull it off i see but you already paid
off five thousand dollars how did you do
that
so we're putting a max amount that we
can into our hsa
and we're doing that monthly and so then
we'll pay
you know down a little bit at a
so we've been putting about four hundred
dollars per month into our hsa accounts
well if you if you clean that right back
out in 10 months you'll be done
yeah so is that we have a fully stocked
emergency plan but should we leave that
alone
and just keep working this plan
there's nothing to keep you from moving
some of that money into the hsa and then
play it out
pay the bill out of the hsa yeah
so move four thousand out of your
emergency fund this is an emergency you
have a medical bill
move four thousand out of it into your
are you out of debt except this
yes okay yeah move four thousand out of
your emergency fund
into your hsa and write the check out of
your hsa and be done with it
all right and then rebuild your
emergency fund
then slow down your hsa at that point
and use that money to rebuild the
emergency fund
right you can do this claire
you can do it guys yeah yeah way to go
good stuff open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five britney's in cleveland
ohio hi brittany welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave how are you great how can we
help
oh my gosh i'm a little nervous um just
a little bit of information i'm a first
generation college student
i'm 25 years old i finished my
bachelor's and my master's degree
in what and i was um i studied sport and
event management and my bachelor's
and then for my master's i studied
organizational leadership
and nonprofit okay so
um i was really fortunate to get my
dream job um which is in sport industry
i'm an event planner on national
sporting events that come to the city
and just the industry is so competitive
and i moved out of state alone for this
opportunity
but unfortunately i only make thirty two
thousand a year and i have sixty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
so my schedule makes it really hard to
get a consistent second job because i
don't work a typical nine to five
sometimes i'll work evening sometimes
i'll work weekends sometimes i'll work
the whole week
or morning tonight and so i'm debating
on if i should leave my dream job
to get a bigger shovel and then try to
get back in but i just worked really
really hard to get here
but i'm also tired of being like so
financially stressed
yeah well you just need a part-time job
that you that's flexible like delivering
pizzas or something
you can turn that on and turn it off you
can turn uber on turn uber off
whenever you're able to work you work
but when you're working your right your
day job
you don't but you're not prohibited from
doing a part-time job you're prohibited
from doing one that you can't
turn on and turn off right i guess
whenever i've tried applying to a couple
of part-time jobs
um like if i only want to work weekends
a lot of them haven't been flexible with
my schedule because i'll have 15 to 20
events a year
and so it's not very consistent so it's
been kind of hard
you're having events right now well not
right now because of the pandemic i'm
really lucky to even have
um yeah so you're not you're not working
a bunch of events right now get a job
yeah you got a whole lot of flexibility
right now
well our events technically start in
february
no they don't i'm just trying to not
this february
in the moment we're planning as things
should yeah that's fine so go work
january and february
and make you some money and if and
depending on how much they gear back
up gear back up with them you cannot use
this as an excuse to not get a second
job
you've got to go get one and that's the
only way you're going to do this
that puts us our of the day ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
you